lourdeurs administratives qui en plus du
coc vide mais le moral des petits
patrons dans les chaussettes emmanuel
macron avait pourtant promis de réformer
ce fameux millefeuille administratif
français le présent qui ajuste supprimer
l'ena et puis locaux vides est passée
par là d'où notre question ce soir les
petits patrons sont-ils les grandes
victimes de la crise qu vide on attend
toujours vos réactions sur le conte
télégramme l'alerté france et c'est
l'heure de notre face à face
est avec nous pour en parler ce soir
donc pierre cabaret débuté la république
en marche de la haute-garonne bonsoir
faire cabaret merci d'être avec nous à
vos côtés charles prax org orateur
national de la cellule riposte de
valérie pécresse candidate évidemment un
dlr à la présidentielle 2022 merci
d'être avec nous une réaction tout
d'abord à ce témoignage qu'on vient
d'entendre on sent vraiment
l'exaspération de notre restaurateur il
a oscillé entre les fermetures les
ouvertures il a respecté les règles il a
critiqué beaucoup la lourdeur
administrative il dit surtout vous
l'avez entendu que le président eh bien
il tient pas ses promesses il devait
simplifier on s'en souvient à la vie des
entrepreneurs avec notamment une réforme
de l'administration
ça n'a pas vraiment été fait pierre au
cabaret d'abord ce que j'entends c'est
l'inquiétude sur les fermetures l
inquiétude sur l'avenir mais sans la
partage avec lui ensuite
et bien
lundi soir nous avons voté nous avons
voté le plan indépendant alors ce plan
indépendant ça simplifie le cadre et ça
effectivement répond un certain nombre
de ces interrogations et puis je
voudrais vous dire que vous avez oublié
une chose mais je vous l'avais pas dit
je suis moi-même artisans alors donc
les entreprises je connais
je connais cette traversée est tout ce
que le gouvernement appuie faire pour
que nous puissions traverser ce moment
et c'est là justement au niveau de la
lourdeur administrative parce que c'est
parce qu'on entend ici ou là quand même
fier cabaret et là je m'adresse à
l'artisan que vous êtes alors la
lourdeur administrative
évidemment ça va mieux et savait encore
mieux puisque lundi soir dernier je vous
dis on a voté ce plan indépendant qui va
nous toucher de près et qui va toucher
de près chaque
entreprise chaque petite entreprise et
chaque entrepreneur et je les remercie
parce que c'est vrai que traverser cette
crise est difficile et il faut un peu
d'espérance aussi vous voyez faire des
grands mouvements la lourdeur années
2000 faille et indigeste oui bof c'est
je suis juriste puisque la profession
moi je suis magistrat et j'ai un petit
peu drège avant j'étais fonctionnaire
chez inspecteurs et donne chez
fonctionne un ministère des finances il
se trouve que alors je ne suis pas
artisans et j'ai une petite connaissance
des règles juridiques applicables aux
chefs d'entreprise et aux entreprises et
même aux particuliers et je suis bien
incapable de même moi de vous dire
combien il ya de milliers de pages par
exemple dans le code général des impôts
français dans la réglementation sociale
applicable enfin c'est on est en france
c'est un truc hallucinant et tous les
chefs d'entreprise qui nous écoutent le
savent très bien leur expert-comptable
savent très bien enfin c'est du délire
c'est à dire qu'on est quand même dans
le pays où le nombre de règles sont
absurdes les règles fiscales des règles
sociales toutes celles qui étrangle
réellement la vie économique du pays qui
pourrissent la vie des français au
quotidien que ce soit les chefs
d'entreprise ou les particuliers si vous
voulez le problème de la france c'est
que rappelez-vous des douze travaux
d'astérix
à l'époque c'était l'immeuble des fous
l'immeuble qui rend fou avec le
formulaire b 30 2 et ben en fait déjà à
l'époque goscinny et uderzo se moquer de
la complexité administrative française
et bien aujourd'hui en 2022 c'est pire
que tout et c'est effectivement un des
grands échecs des manuels macron c'est
de ne pas avoir du tout simplifier les
règles à tel point que vous avez même un
candidat à la présidentielle qui vient
de se présenter en disant moi je veux
enfin simplifier les règles donc c'est
énorme là dessus il faut arrêter de
prendre les gens pour des imbéciles
il suffit simplement de regarder un code
général des impôts il suffit d'aller
regarder la réglementation de l'urssaf
un d'ailleurs même des services de
l'urssaf des fois ne comprennent même
pas leurs règles il ne savait même pas
les appliquer pour les gencives aller
sur internet ils regardent légifrance 1
le site internet des règles juridiques
applicables on vote d'énormes vous êtes
député à l'assemblée nationale vous
voter des lois tout le temps on crée
d'énormes l'europe nous rajoute des
normes
on n'arrête pas les lois les décrets à
les arrêter les circulaires tout nous a
plus personne ne comprend rien à rien le
dernier exemple en date voilà c'était le
protocole sanitaire dans les écoles un
pataquès incommensurable depuis
plusieurs jours on voit ce que ça donne
voilà à tel point que même le président
de la république rue comprendre a dit
oui non là ça a plu quoi voilà donc non
là véritablement et c'est d'ailleurs une
des raisons on pourra parler peut-être
après deux passes pour les restaurateurs
les actions des petites crises etc mais
oui là on touche du doigt véritablement
un vrai problème français c'est cette
complexité administrative
qui est source d'incompréhension qui est
source d'erreurs qui est source de
fraude aussi parce que plus vous
complexifier les règles plus vous
permettez aux gens de les contourner
donc on est au coeur du mal français et
hasta évidemment ça joue de cette crise
sanitaire on l'a entendu avec ce
témoignage d'où notre question du soir
les petits patrons sont-ils des grandes
victimes de la crise qu vide c'est vrai
que la situation des des restaurateurs
elle fait pas vraiment rêver on va
regarder un groupement national des
indépendants hôteliers les restaurations
qui a fait les les comptes avec les
annulations et la désertification des
restaurants en termes d'activité qu'est
ce que ça donne et bien regardez
- 93 % pour les cafetiers en baisse
d'activité évidemment des restaurants en
décembre 2021 moins 80 11 % pour les
traiteurs moins 85 pour les
restaurateurs ça fait lourd tout de même
pierre cabaret qu'est ce que ça vous
inspire ces chiffres sachant que ça y
est maintenant le quoi qu'il en coûte et
bien c'est terminé 1 d'abord je voudrais
revenir sur l'aspect très noir ce que
vous donnez et que tes chers messieurs
si nous avions ce trou sans fond que
vous imaginez que vous laisser imaginer
on n'aurait pas un demi million
d'emplois créés cette terre deux
dernières années on aurait des pride ans
et des faillites d'entreprises en
pagaille alors que depuis 1986 eh bien
nous n'avons jamais eu un taux de
faillite aussi aussi faible donc je
crois qu'il faut pas noircir le tableau
mais arrêtons de marc sur ce tableau
arrêtez-vous aussi de noircir le tableau
et vouloir si c'est pour une raison
parce que finalement ce que pécresse
propose macron l'a déjà fait et ça nous
l'avons fait encore hier soir avec avec
cette idée là dotons si on prend les
quartiers évidemment que les castillon
une baisse évidemment mais cette baisse
c'est pas le quoi qu'il en coûte qui est
important c'est cette baisse elle est
compensée par des aides et effectivement
on traverse une mesure avec des mesures
encourageant et bien on traverse une
situation difficile il faut arrêter de
donner une image aussi
dans ce bar exception les aime continue
le fonds de solidarité entreprises
continuent jusqu'à la fin du mois donc
les aides sont pas arrêtées et ensuite
les aides en fonction de ce qui arrive
pourront avoir une réactivité plus
importante donc je crois que sur ça il
faut vraiment être dans l'actualité je
crois pour avoir une vision un peu
loyale c'était le 26 mai ce que vous
répondez à kabacouma voilà ce que
valérie pécresse aimerait faire
justement sur ce type de problématique
macron l'a déjà fait non il faudra alors
sur les aides et soit à traverser avec
ce qu'on appelle quoi qu'il en coûte etc
il faut effectivement reconnaître bord
c'est pas emmanuel macron bruno le maire
s'est pas des ministres le président qui
décide en réalité ce type de dispositif
en plus non mais tout à fait ce type de
dispositif ils ne sont conçus au
ministère des finances en l'économie et
des finances par des hauts
fonctionnaires qui sont compétents et
face à la crise qu vite parce qu'il ya
une décision politique un nombre donné
de fermeture de confinement est ca de
l'activité il a été décidé de mettre en
place deux choses le chômage partiel qui
a d'ailleurs été mis en place de manière
open bars et donc avec des fraudes
monstrueuse parce que le gouvernement
n'avait pas voulu écouter notamment
partis politiques plus délicat vais
proposer des amendements pour sécuriser
les paiements moralité on s'est fait
voler des millions et des dizaines de
millions voire des centaines de millions
d'euros par les fraudeurs habituels
qu'on connaît mais bon ça c'est comme ça
et après il ya eu aussi dispositif du
fonds de solidarité qui est un petit peu
différent mais c'est dispose il est bien
sûr les pêcheuses ce qu'on appelle des
prêts garantis par l'état qui ont permis
effectivement à tout un tas
d'entreprises de la plus petite à la
plus grande d'essayer de traverser la
crise et effectivement d'ailleurs si
vous regardez les statistiques des des
faillites vous rendez compte que malgré
une baisse très importante du pib un
nombre d'activités économiques en
réalité vous avez eu une baisse des
défaillances d'autres enfin de petites
entreprises sur les plus grandes
entreprises vous avez une augmentation
très forte des défaillances
d'entreprises des dernières fois plus
78% de mémoire d'après une étude
deloitte qui avaient été publiées en mai
2021 est par contre sur les petites
entreprises les artisans les commerçants
on avait une baisse des défaillances
d'entreprises qui peut apparaître contre
intuitif en fait ça c'est le mécanisme
de fonctionnement du pge qui a été conçu
par les fonctionnaires de bercy
évidemment le gouvernement
sans en tirer gloire parce que c'est lui
qui est aux affaires s'il a tort de
s'inquiéter ce restaurateur non alors il
a il peut avoir tort de s'inquiéter par
rapport aux aides parce que malgré tout
comme nous sommes nous en aller année
électorale il mène le nacre ont
évidemment maintient la perfusion du
poids qu'il en coûte parce que sinon
vous aurez ya un nombre de défaillances
très important et ça ne peut pas se le
permettre en année électorale en
revanche là où il a raison de
s'inquiéter c'est sur la baisse de
fréquentation vous avez souligné et
cette baisse de fréquentation par
exemple elle est due à des mesures là
qui pour la peine sont des mesures pour
politicards et donc des décisions
politiques qui sont parfois totalement
absurde permettez-moi de le dire mais
quand vous êtes dans un bistrot et qu'on
vient vous dire non vous n'avez pas le
droit de boire votre café debout faut le
boire à 6 je suis désolé mais le virus
du coc vide ils veulent pas simplement
au dessus d'un mètre cinquante quoi
voilà donc et sacs d'ailleurs tout le
monde a rigolé et tout le monde s'est
moqué de ces mesures un petit peu
absurdes qui ont été prises et qui sont
symptomatiques de la manière dont le
gouvernement parfois à gers cette
affaire là de manière un petit peu
bizarre et du moins des gens ne
comprennent pas certaines décisions qui
sont prises
oui allez-y elle désigne non je voulais
justement bondir pascal des qui nous dit
tout dépend des petits patrons milliards
il n'y a jamais eu de crise de co2 dues
covin bon lui c'est son avis voilà ça
n'engage que lui mais une crise
politique due à de l'incompétence
flagrante et qui a mis plein de gens
debout ou à genoux non là je m'inscris
en fois n'y a pas une incompétence des
gens encore une fois l'an c'est mon côté
ancien de bercy qui parle mais les
fonctionnaires du ministère des finances
qui ont conçu ses plombs qui les ont mis
en oeuvre etc sont au contraire très
compétent et on leur doit d'avoir passé
la crise mais comme depuis des siècles
on doit à l'état au système de l'état
globalement de permettre à la france de
traverser les crises de régime des
crises
là vous mettez le point sur le véritable
problème c'est que quoi qu'il en coûte
il va bien falloir je rembourse un
moment donné et c'est clair on a cramé
la caisse quand je dit très justement
valérie pécresse on continue de la cram
et et dans le même temps il ya des
décisions mais bon c'est pas le sujet du
soir mais qui sont prises qui sont assez
étonnantes en matière de sécurisation
des recettes de lutte contre la fraude
etc etc ça on l'a
vraiment le bienvenu pour en parler un
autre jour ce défaut de gestion qu'elle
fait allusion aux téléspectateurs des
fautes de gestion vous répondez quoi
vous c'est vrai que quand on voit cette
là on va pas faire donc c'est un débat
sur l'école mais quand on voit répondent
deux choses le système la grève de
l'école que
notre président et est à la manoeuvre
jusqu'à au match de l'an prochain au
mois de mai prochain valérie pécresse
effectivement peut toujours
allégué certaines certaines choses on
peut tout se permettre quand on est donc
on ne va pas se permettre nous de faire
des supputations complètement farfelu
j'aimerais sur d'arrêt hier un budget
que nous n'avons pas alors on peut
toujours chercher et contrôler ça je
suis absolument d'accord et tout le
monde est d'accord avec ça on peut
contrôler il faut quand même raison
garder surtout cet argent hypothétique
dont vous parlez et qui n'existe pas
donc sur les hauts fonctionnaires moi je
suis ravie veut parler vous me parlez
aux fonctionnaires alors ça c'est
formidable aux fonctionnaires qui sont
compétents et à côté de ça vous nous
expliquer que finalement ces mêmes hauts
fonctionnaires 1 parce que vous
l'expliqué aussi nous pondent des lois
complètement dégénéré écoutez moi je
suis pas d'accord je suis pas d'accord
avec ça il faut avoir une cohérence et
ses hauts fonctionnaires ne pompe pas
les lois qui sont inapplicables ils
pondent des lois et il est promu les
noues premier comptait loi chanson happy
place le député là je vous et vos
parties jouées à des lois je vais vous
des chutes et qu'il ait jeté vous parlez
vous êtes dans les zones à la république
qui les propulse avez vous me racontez
que ce sont les hauts fonctionnaires qui
les font effectivement que vous avez
raison mesure est elle prépare les
mesures vous me raconter leurs
compétences et vous dénigrer leurs
pompes et en cela il faudrait imaginer
options fonctionner oui oui mais les
eaux fraîches le maire c'est vrai on
c'est facile de taper sur les gens quand
ils d'abord quand ils sont pas là
ensuite si ça vous a pas invités pour
être d'accord et si c'est oui oui oui on
sera pas d'accord la chute d'ailleurs on
n'est pas d'accord vous une chose oui
c'est que nous on gère et madame
pécresse imagine qu'elle peut gérer mais
en prenant la raison est ainsi 70% des
lycées en ile-de-france ont besoin d'une
rénovation extrême c'est une gestion
assez acial enfin patrick reed en tout
cas et pour moi l'éducation c'est
important et c'est important d'y mettre
l'argent nécessaire
va-t-on pas revenir à nos moutons
excusez moi avec question quand même les
petits patrons senti les grandes
victimes de la crise vous disiez non
mais enfin regarder quand même ces
chiffres sur les défaillances
d'entreprises les secteurs les plus
impactés hébergement et restauration n'y
reviens moi 60.7 enseignement santé
action sociale services aux ménages - 51
commerce réparation auto - 47 ça l'air
de rien mais enfin ce sont quand même
des des petits métiers des métiers de
proximité
vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec ça les
plus petits n'ont pas souffert dont sa
fille se trouvait bien sûr que s'ils ont
souffert mais si vous voulez le
dispositif dead et ge chômage partiel
fonds de solidarité a permis aux plus
petites entreprises de mieux traverser
la crise d'ailleurs que les grandes mais
c'est d'ailleurs tout le tout la
question c'est que là pour l'instant
l'économie est sous perfusion on a une
espèce de soviétisation de l'économie
les gens sont habitués à m mais si c'est
un mot qui est tout à fait choisi d'être
tout sauf des dix nations mais bien sûr
mais
quand les salariés du port par les boks
ont payé par l'état bon j'en appelle ça
la soviétisation ginola économie et ça
va poser un problème c'est de penser que
j'entendrais des choses plus haute et
plus compétentes franchement là écoutez
monsieur le député si vous voulez parler
de compétences dans ce cas là je vous
refais un cours de droit constitutionnel
ce sont les parlementaires qui votent
les lois pas les hauts fonctionnaires
c'est le président de la république il
est promu par les députés et bien moi
j'en ai besoin je s'agit de la
production des gros je vais faire je
vais faire donc comme vous faites encore
et constitution je vais vous faire un
cours d'économie puisque moi-même sur
six ans et on travers cette crise et
bien finalement c'est vrai et vous avez
dit on a promulgué un certain nombre
d'événements qui ont fait qu les gens
peuvent traverser cette crise
aujourd'hui est c'est magique parce que
nous avons eu un mois de faillite que
vous préférez une faillite vous préférez
des gens de hors jeu les sims est votre
fonds de commerce il insulté puis
l'avoir aidé à voir les chômeurs et vont
fondre comme alors pas le mien mais moi
je vais bien des gens jours à l'avancé
sur cette photo n'a jamais eu dans ce
que sous emmanuel macron nom des choses
il importe quoi là aussi chômeurs a
baissé de 1,6 million 700 mille
reprenant la chine et oui mais alors
avec vos chiffres vous savez les
chiffres on leur fait dire tout ce que
l'on veut bien sûr vous avez aujourd'hui
âgée de sept cent mille chômeurs de plus
que du temps de nicolas sarkozy tenait à
des récentes années art il en a un
chiffre lui fait dire ce que l'on a à la
fin du mois ces essais rien d'autre
c'est la maman celle ci pense que l'on a
aussi vous avez assez mignon 3 c'est
bien qu'ils aident pour l'europe 1,6
million sept cent mille chômeurs c'est
ça le bilan de manuel macron et c'est là
dessus vous pouvez dire tout ce que vous
voulez de dire tout va bien tout est
pour le mieux dans le meilleur des
mondes ce n'est pas vrai maintenant s'il
se disant est exact en tout cas madame
pécresse devrait être caracoler en tête
pour les projets qu'elle a été justement
vous me donnez une transition parfaite
jean-pierre cabaret les sondages et
là-bas premier tour bpt voudrais dire
c'est que des chiffres et ce ne sont que
des sondages mais tout de même emmanuel
macron moins trois points 1 sur ce
sondage 23% valérie pécresse 17% à
égalité avec marine le pen ça il ya du
changement j'imagine ça vous fait
plaisir jane pratt
les vaccins on emmerde au maximum les
non-vaccinés ça coûté quelques points
emmanuel macron vous regrettez vous en
tant que le soutien du président ses
propos moi je vais pas commenter les
propos d'un président de la république
du président de la république qui se
veut un café sans une interview je
reçois dans ma permanence les personnes
qui sont contre la vaccination j'en
avais eu lundi matin qui m'expose toutes
les raisons d'être contre et je vais
répond avec toutes les raisons d'être
pourrais je les renvoie sur un très bel
article du monde du 5 janvier dernier
sur justement ce vaccin la rn messager
qui propose à qui qui entraîne vers plus
de 2 comment dire nous avons découvert
des choses ça découvert des traitements
contre les cancers donc je crois que il
faut aussi
révocation des nations arctiques
médecins
résidents non moi je veux pas revenir
dessus sont pas ceux sont pas les
miennes et j'ai lu des ce et puis
finalement et bien et certainement c'est
très ennuyeux quand même d'avoir des
personnes qui ont acquis une telle
mauvaise foi de vente cette vaccination
et des arguments qui n'en sont pas ouais
je l'apprends de sens on puisse emporter
un peu hein le mot de la fin pour vous
justement sur ce sondage commandé quatre
lectures la lecture elle est très simple
emmanuel macron non pas le prison la
république en fait le candidat à faut
arrêter de prendre les gens on sait pas
mais s'il emmanuel macron un candidat
mais il est toujours président de la
république et que le président de la
république dise qu'ils emmerdent une
catégorie des français et bien il le
paye cash 3 points en moins dans les
sondages voilà je crois que c'est très
clair et petit à petit les gens à un
moment donné vont finir par ouvrir les
yeux parce qu'il commence par se faire
ouvrir les oreilles par des mots qui ne
sont pas les mots qu on attendre d'un
président de la république sur le second
tour de ce sondage 50 50 c'est la
première bras c'est pour ça qu'on a tenu
à le sortir
emmanuel macron a déjà été battu dans
certains sondages par valérie pécresse
évidemment aujourd'hui dans ce sondage
là afssa les sondages il y en a beaucoup
dans ce sondage là ils sont à 50-50
c'est à dire que dans la main d'erreurs
ça veut dire dans ce sondage là l'un ou
l'autre peut gagner ce sondage est très
intéressant pourquoi parce qu'il montre
aux français qu'en réalité la seule
personne qui est capable de sortir le
sortant évidemment les français en ont
marre des manuels macro et donc ils
veulent sortir le sortant la seule
personne qui est capable de le faire
c'est valérie pécresse et ça ça parle à
tous les électeurs tant de droite que de
gauche d'ailleurs d'ailleurs quand vous
regardez les transferts de voix vous
rendez compte que valérie pécresse sur
ce deuxième tour rassemble rassemble à
droite rassemblent au centre rassemble à
gauche avons beaucoup en ile de france
parce qu'elle est très majoritairement
seront ce sondage là en ile-de-france au
deuxième tour est en réalité on a quand
même le sentiment qu'aujourd'hui les
choses sont claires si on veut sortir
emmanuel macron il faut voter valérie
pécresse vous êtes soutient évidemment
de valérie pécresse et d'élections dans
moins de trois mois merci en tout cas
charles
était avec nous